in der rue des efre 40 im herzen von
paris befindet sich der hauptsitz von
care in dem luxus giganten zu dem neben
gucci als hauptmarke auch yves sarault
bottega veneta und valencia gehören ein
meisterwerk von 1600 mit garten einem
17.000 quadratmeter großen gebäude und
einer kirche im inneren der gucci hat
befindet sich in der wir mit renate 79
in mailand
35.000 quadratmeter in einer ehemaligen
restaurierten flugzeugfabrik es umfasst
einem sechsstöckigen turm für büros und
designer einen showroom einen raum für
modeschauen und auch einen wilden wald
aber in der via industrie a 19 in qadam
kino in diesem anonymen gebäude zwischen
der autobahn und dem tennisplatz werden
80 prozent der gewinne der gesamten
kehring gruppe erzielt einen nettogewinn
von 1 7 milliarden franken im jahr 2017
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nachdem sie 20 jahre lang über die lg in
campino steuern im tessin gezeigt hat
hat das unternehmen das zur kehring
gruppe gehört das finanzamt in den
ländern zurück erobert in denen die
arbeiter den reichtum produzieren dieses
jahr verlässt der größte steuerzahler
den kanton
gemeinde campino hat dies bestätigt hier
machte das was alle gutsche ihnen
jährlich drei viertel der
steuereinnahmen aus
was genau hat ihnen lg im dezember wenn
ich mich nicht irre gesagt
es war november sie teilten uns mit dass
wir aufgrund einer änderung in ihrem
unternehmen in den nächsten jahren
weniger steuern erhalten würden
genau wie viel weniger
wir sagen wir im jahr 2009 10 80 prozent
weniger als ihr üblicher standard und ab
2020 dann 95 prozent weniger
was also bleibt sind nur fünf prozent
der einnahmen die bisher von lg bezahlt
wurden
grob gesagt ja
der konzern wird in der schweiz deutlich
weniger steuern zahlen und hat bereits
angekündigt vorerst 150 mitarbeiter zu
versetzen campino wird jedes jahr acht
millionen franken verlieren der kanton
sogar mehr als 20
hier ist der platz mit den steinen
granit oder was weiß ich und drumherum
wird die bepflanzung sein einschließlich
etwaiger dekoration des platzes pflanzen
und andere dinge
campino mit 1500 einwohnern bis heute
die reichste stadt des tessins ist das
symbol für die enormen einnahmen die der
luxus riese jährlich garantiert mit
diesem geld werden das neue gemeindehaus
und der platz fertig gestellt eine
investition von rund 10 millionen
franken
[Musik]
es ist wirklich groß war es eine
ungewöhnliche investition für eine stadt
mit 1500 einwohnern sobald sie das sind
große räume die platz für entwicklung
bieten
möchten sie den wegfall der einnahmen
aus ihren wirtschaftlichen ressourcen
es hat die dinge ein bisschen verändert
früher waren wir onkel dagobert es war
nur so weil wir glück hatten und wir
wir haben die mittel gut verwaltet und
können sicherlich die nächsten fünf
jahre ohne probleme weiter machen
in diesen jahren hat ktm pilot 30
millionen franken beiseite gelegt die
ist der gemeinde nun ermöglichen das
schlimmste zu verhindern
[Musik]
das war muss ich sagen eine kalte dusche
nicht nur für die gemeinde sondern auch
für den kanton und folglich auch auf
bundesebene und ich denke wir haben kein
recht uns aus irgendeinem grund zu
beschweren
umsatzrückgang bei alg ii worauf ist das
zurückzuführen
auf die umstrukturierung die sie
innerhalb des unternehmens hatten das
ist die veränderung die beziehungen die
wir hatten sind gut
wir sollten hier diskretion wahren denn
das unternehmen selbst hat auch immer
diskretion wahren lassen
heute wird jedoch gegen den konzern von
der staatsanwaltschaft mailand ermittelt
wonach er gerade über die tessiner
niederlassung lg luxury goods
international essay zwischen 2011 und
2017 steuern in höhe von 1,4 milliarden
euro hinterzogen und einnahmen in höhe
von 14,5 milliarden euro nicht
deklariert haben soll
wurde die tatsache dass gegen sie wegen
steuerhinterziehung ermittelt wird von
dem unternehmen bei ihrem treffen
erwähnt
nein wir haben nicht über untersuchungen
gesprochen auch weil es nicht an uns
liegt zu wissen oder nicht zu wissen
warum gegen sie ermittelt wird wenn
gegen sie ermittelt wird
aber wir haben von den zinsen profitiert
die sie uns gegeben haben und das ist
genug für uns ich persönlich habe nicht
zu beanstanden es tut mir leid dass
dieses geld woanders hingeht aber
solange sie hier waren hat sich niemand
beschwert denn es gab nur einen verlust
zu verzeichnen
die wälder auf kantonaler ebene bei den
steuern
haben sie sich jemals gefragt wie ein
unternehmen wie lg so viele gewinne im
kino erzielen konnte
wir haben uns nie darum gekümmert wie
sie diese gewinne erzielt haben
der lge hauptsitz in campino
erwirtschaftete 2017 einen reingewinn
von fast 1,7 milliarden franken zum
vergleich das ist ein höherer gewinn als
bei swisscom und doppelt so hoch wie bei
swatch wie wir bereits in einem bericht
von vor zwei jahren aufzeigten hat lg
mit nur 800 angestellten im vergleich zu
30.000 angestellten im rest der welt
seit jahren den größten teil der gewinne
des multinationalen luxuskonzerns
kehring in der schweiz konzentriert wo
er eine privilegierte kantonale
besteuerung von acht prozent genießt ein
äußerst wettbewerbsfähige satz im
vergleich zu den steuern im rest der
welt
was war die funktion der lg die diese
stratosphärischen gewinne rechtfertigte
eine quelle die der spitze des
unternehmens sehr nahesteht hat mit uns
gesprochen wir durften weder sein
gesicht filmen noch details über ihn
preisgeben wir konnten lediglich unsere
gespräche aufzeichnen und nun davon
berichten fehring erklärt dass die
tessiner niederlassung kommerzielle
tätigkeiten ausübt aber was geschah
wirklich in der lg
es gab große büros in denen den ganzen
tag über rechnungen gedruckt wurden mehr
nicht in der schweiz wurden logistische
und buchhalterische aufgaben
wahrgenommen
gab es oder gibt es wertschöpfungs
positionen
auf keinen fall es gibt überhaupt keine
es gibt nichts kein käufer ist jemals in
campino gewesen
haben sie campino gesehen glauben sie
kann im kino repräsentiert die marke ich
meine es ist ein lagerhaus einen hangar
der verkauf und gucci findet in mailand
statt
jährigen erklärte aber dass lg eine
kommerzielle plattform sei
ich habe nie gesehen dass bei lg
gehandelt wurde es gab eine
institutionalisierte falschdarstellung
dessen was lg für steuerzwecke tat eine
art betrug und proton in breuberg
eldrup warum verlässt die kerngruppe das
tessin wie haben sie ihren weggang
begründet
der grund im tessin zu bleiben waren die
steuern und nur die steuern mit dem
wegfall der steuervergünstigungen
seitdem die italienische
staatsanwaltschaft gegen sie wegen
steuerhinterziehung ermittelt er gibt
der verbleib im tessin keinen sinn mehr
denn der würde nur betrieblichen
effizienz und einen anstieg der kosten
bedeuten
in der zwischenzeit hat die lg ihre
mitarbeiter bereits über die verlagerung
nach italien insbesondere nach novara
informiert wo gucci ein logistikzentrum
und ein werk besitzt das bereits
erweitert wird über seine eigenen
entscheidungen bewahrt das unternehmen
äußerste diskretion
aber es ist uns gelungen mit einigen
mitarbeitern zu sprechen auch in diesem
fall wird niemand zu erkennen sein
das einzige was sie von einem wollen ist
wir mussten eine
geheimhaltungsverpflichtung
unterschreiben sie wollen nicht dass
jemand darüber spricht es geht das
gerücht um dass sie bald mit allem
umziehen werden bei lg sind die gehälter
im vergleich zu den schweizerischen
standards viel niedriger sie liegen
zwischen 3400 und 3800 franken pro monat
wenn man bereits etwas erfahrung hat für
die versetzung nach italien wurde
dasselbe gehalt vorgeschlagen allerdings
mit italienischer besteuerung das heißt
40 prozent weniger
für diejenigen die bereits in italien
leben also fast alle in der firma ist
das in ordnung aber die wenigen
schweizer die dort arbeiten wurden in
die knie gezwungen
wurden dort irgendwelche kommerziellen
aktivitäten durchgeführt oder wichtige
entscheidungen getroffen
das war eine rein logistische und
buchhalterische angelegenheit der rest
ist in campino sicher nie passiert
wir wussten irgendwie das ist für lg
einen etwas fadenscheinigen grund gab in
der schweiz zu sein
akademie - ist am zum beispiel werden in
campino etiketten gedruckt und an die
lieferanten geschickt man hat uns immer
gesagt dass wir das tun müssen um zu
zeigen dass wir dort an der produktion
beteiligt sind
kennen sie die etiketten die in die
kleidung eingenähten genau aber sie
sagten sie müssten in der schweiz
gemacht werden und das war's haben die
arbeiter sie gemein sein ein früher
haben wir das gemacht sie die
büroangestellten ja wir haben uns
abgewechselt um uns um diese dinge zu
kümmern
aber die steuern werden dort bezahlt wo
die hauptaktivitäten stattfinden wie
konnten sie rechtfertigen dass eine
reine logistik niederlassung in campino
gewinne in höhe von 17 milliarden
fremden erwirtschaftet diese frage
scheint bei gucci im mittelpunkt der
überlegungen gestanden zu haben denn je
größer sie wurde desto mehr musste sie
rechtfertigen dass wertschöpfende
tätigkeiten in der tessiner
niederlassung durchgeführt wurden wo sie
steuern seite die lösung eine liste von
22 manager die offenbar im tessin
arbeiten und wohnen
es gab die rektoren die sich als unsere
manager ausgaben obwohl sie es in
wirklichkeit nicht warnen sie schienen
ein büro in campino zu haben aber wir
haben sie nie gesehen die wichtigen
männer waren sicherlich nicht in campino
tatsächlich wurden ihre büros als
besprechungsräume genutzt weil jeder
wusste dass sie nie da waren
aber eine residenz sie hatten einen
gefälschten wohnsitz um einen beweis
dafür zu liefern dass wichtige
führungsaufgaben in der schweiz
wahrgenommen wurden gleichzeitig stellte
die gruppe diesen managern büro
sekretariat organisatorische und
operative unterstützung in italien zur
verfügung
wie oft waren diese manager im tessin
sehr selten fast nie
haben sie jemals wirklich in diesen
wohnungen gelebt wie sudan kuba
sie haben dort gewohnt die
wohnungsverwaltung wurde den
angestellten überlassen einige
assistenten wurden geschickt um von zeit
zu zeit die post abzuholen und die
stromzähler zu kontrollieren indem sie
ab und zu das licht einschalteten und
die waschmaschinen laufen ließen damit
der stromverbrauch glaubwürdiger war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie sie aus dieser internen e-mail
ersehen können hat carey selbst die
versetzungen in die schweiz vorbereitet
und zwar nicht für irgendwelche stellen
sondern für schlüsselpositionen im
unternehmen zb robert trikots leiter des
marketings diana zanetti leiterin des
merchandising fabio so stellvertretender
leiter des einzelhandels und mehr leiter
der personalabteilung leiter der
schulabteilung die liste ist lang nach
unseren informationen hat praktisch
keiner von ihnen jemals einen fuß ins
tessin gesetzt für zwei personen ist
jedoch eine sonderbehandlung reserviert
die beiden höchsten gucci
spitzenpositionen patrizio di marco und
marco bizarre
zu unserer rettung haben wir einige sehr
interessante und exklusive dokumente
erhalten es handelt sich um dieselben
dokumente die mediapart erhalten und mit
einem konsortium von
enthüllungsjournalisten geteilt hat
der bis 2014 im amt war war offenbar in
der schweiz ansässig wo er eine
pauschalsteuer regelung genuss
mit dem mietvertrag in der hand sehen
wir uns an wo der gucci präsident wohnte
[Musik]
wissen sie ob patrizio di marco ihr
gewohnt hat
ich kenne ihn nicht ceo von gucci haben
sie ihn jemals hier gesehen die marke
und nein darf ich ihnen ein bild zeigen
damit sie mir sagen können ob sie ihnen
jemals gesehen haben ja wie lange leben
sie schon hier vier jahre vier jahre
okay ja diese person kennen sie sie
haben sie ihn jemals gesehen
tut mir leid ich kenne ihn nicht
erleben sie schon lange hier ja
mindestens vier oder fünf jahre
wenn ich ihnen ein bild zeige haben sie
ihnen vielleicht schon mal hier gesehen
auf keinen fall sie haben ihn nie
gesehen
[Musik]
die marke konnte nämlich in der wohnung
die wohnung meiner ist leer seit ich
hier bin es steht also schon seit vier
jahren leer auf jeden fall
die marke wurde hier nie gesehen allein
die prämie für kleidung die die marke
von der firma erhielt war höher als die
jahresmiete dieser wohnung kann man
wirklich glauben dass der präsident von
gucci mit seinem jahresumsatz von
mehreren millionen eine 3600 franken
wohnung im ersten stock mit blick auf
die bahn angemietet hatte
[Musik]
die 1500 quadratmeter 44 zimmer fünf
etagen die sich über drei hausnummern
erstrecken mit der adresse in der hand
erreichen wir eine andere art von
aussicht auf die die fenster von wie
marco blicken
[Musik]
wer ist da guten morgen ich wollte
fragen ob es möglich ist mit herrn
patrizio di marco zu sprechen
wer fragt ich bin anna bernasconi die
arbeiten für das schweizer fernsehen
schweizer fernsehen ja nein denn er ist
nicht da
erst nicht zu hause nein er ist nicht zu
hause die marko schrank mit seiner
tochter und seiner frau in dieser villa
auf dem see nicolo in einem der
angesehensten viertel roms zu wohnen
die berühmte ehemalige designerin von
gucci stand tatsächlich am fenster
ich habe mich gefragt ob es möglich ist
mit herrn di marco zu sprechen er ist
nicht zu hause erst nicht zu hause ich
wollte ihnen um einige informationen
bitten über laufende ermittlungen
ich weiß davon nichts ich werde mit
meinem mann darüber sprechen
ich wollte etwas über seinen wohnsitz in
der schweiz erfahren er ist in italien
ansässig
gegenwärtig aber früher war er in der
schweiz ansässig hören sie ich rufe sie
zurück
das ist die informationen die ich haben
wollte
ok danke
[Musik]
dasselbe gilt auch für marco bizarre den
derzeitigen vorsitzenden der gruppe
pauschalpreis wohnsitz in vico morcote
wohin er jedoch nie einen fuss gesetzt
zu haben scheint
[Musik]
ist das nicht der typ der ganz oben
wurmte ihn schon mal jemand gesucht hat
sicherlich haben schon andere
journalisten nach ihm gesucht es ist
schon jemand aus italien gekommen um ihn
zu suchen aber ich habe ihn nie gesehen
was wäre wenn ich ihnen ein bild zeigen
würde warten sie kurz ich komme
ich habe ihn nie gesehen serien da jetzt
auf dem foto aber nein ich kann ihnen
nicht helfen wie lange leben sie schon
in diesem haus 38 jahre 38 jahre genau
hier ich hätte ihn sehen müssen
zumindest im auto genau aber dass der
ceo von gucci genau hier gewohnt haben
soll
das haben sie auch nicht gewusst ich
habe nie gesehen nein
sowohl gegen bizarre als auch gegen die
marco wird von der staatsanwaltschaft
mailand ermittelt bizarre arbeitet und
lebt in mailand und zwar seit jahren im
dachgeschoss eines der exklusivsten
gebäude hinter der piazza duomo ich
werde ihnen ein bild zeigen
kennen sie ihn kommt er hierher um
kaffee zu trinken da kam ein paar mal
vorbei ja
er wohnt hier
in jazz
[Musik]
ich habe bizzarrini im lg gesehen
zumindest soweit ich weiss bizarre sagen
wir mal er ist leicht zu erkennen sie
haben ihn noch nie gesehen nein ich habe
ihn nie gesehen und ich habe noch nie
kollegen sagen hören dass die bizarre
gesehen haben
patrizio di marco nein auch nicht
die marke und bezahle haben den
steuervorteil genutzt und sind nie nach
campino gekommen nun das management das
sind die funktionen mit mehrwert sie
sollten in der schweiz bleiben und ihre
aufgaben dort erfüllen so dass die marge
in der schweiz korrekt zugewiesen würde
welche überprüfungen wurden durchgeführt
als man den beiden super managern die
marke und bizarre das global ist ische
regime gewerbe hat man nie eine
unregelmäßigkeit in bezug auf die
herkunft ihrer einkünfte bemerkt die
beitrags- abteilung lehnte ein interview
diesbezüglich ab und berief sich in
einer schriftlichen erklärung auf das
steuergeheimnis
soviel ich weiß haben die behörden das
nie überprüft ja die wahrheit ist dass
das einfach niemand kontrolliert hat
[Musik]
und wie wurde die marco bezahlt es gibt
neue vertrauliche dokumente die
ehemalige nummer eins von gucci erhielt
demnach zusätzlich zu ihrem regulären
gehalt in italien eine zweite vergütung
als berater diese vergütung wurde im
ersten jahr von der lg inka dem kino
gezeigt bis di marco im jahr 2010 die
globalisierung in der schweiz beantragte
allerdings dass man kein schweizer
einkommen haben wenn man diese
steuervorteile erhalten will wie konnte
das problem gelöst werden ganz einfach
durch die übertragung des
beratervertrags von der tessiner lg auf
eine gewisse castella ein unternehmen
mit sitz in luxemburg eine inoffizielle
vergütung die über eine ihrer offshore
gesellschaften in panama wenn die
international mit einem konto in
singapur erzielt wurde es gibt nur
wenige zweifel daran dass die doppelten
verträge der reguläre in italien und
dieser beratungsvertrag mit dem
luxemburgischen unternehmen kastel
nichts weiter waren als ein spielchen um
einen großen teil der vergütung unter
der hand sein zu können die beiden
verträge wurden am selben tag
unterzeichnet die bonus mitteilungen
wurden immer zu denselben terminen
verschickt und von demselben präsidenten
von kehring kino unterzeichnet das wurde
sogar von di marco zum zeitpunkt der
unterbrechung seiner geschäftsbeziehung
mit der gruppe bestätigt in der er den
vertrag mit castella in bezug auf die
selbe und einzige geschäftsbeziehung
definiert
[Musik]
in nur vier jahren zwischen 2010 und
2014 wurden von castella nach panama
monatliche überweisungen in höhe von
insgesamt 24 millionen franken getätigt
und zwar steuerfrei in der schweiz kam
die marke in den genuss einer minimalen
pauschalsteuer von 130 tausend franken
das heißt er zahlte nur zwei prozent
steuern auf sein tatsächliches einkommen
das ist 20 mal weniger als er in italien
hätte zahlen müssen dasselbe gilt für
bizarre bei einer jährlichen netto
vergütung von 8 millionen entgingen 6
millionen steuern durch luxemburg alles
in allem liegt der vorteil dieses
komplexen verdeckten zahlungssystems
jedoch bei caring selbst das seinen
präsidenten dreimal weniger zahlen
konnte als sie tatsächlich kosteten zum
beispiel für die 24 millionen die andy
marko in panama gingen hätte sie 63
millionen mit steuern zahlen müssen eine
beträchtliche ersparnis und eine
möglichkeit die besten manager
einzustellen
wir sind auf dem weg nach luxemburg
einer steueroase im herzen europas wo
das gesetz keine steuern auf im ausland
erwirtschaftete einkünfte vorsieht der
boulevard de la petrus 124 rastede hat
die gleiche adresse wie ein viel
wichtigeres unternehmen care in
luxemburg es die muttergesellschaft die
unter anderem den lukrativsten zweig der
gruppe kontrolliert die tessiner lg
ein unternehmen mit hunderten von aktien
und milliarden von dividenden hat seinen
sitz bei dieser firma die bereits voll
ausgestattete büros vermietet
[Musik]
ist es möglich mit jemandem von kehring
oder castella zu sprechen
es ist niemand da
niemand ist ihr okay darf ich sie fragen
wie viele personen in ihren büros
arbeiten
komme ich ihnen schon sagte ohne ihre
genehmigung kann ich keine auskunft
geben
er ist der direktor des unternehmens
gibt es einen leiter für die beiden
büros
ohne genehmigung kann ich keine weiteren
auskünfte erteilen sie können keine
auskunft geben
sie lassen uns nicht hinein aber nach
dem grundriss zu urteilen den uns eine
quelle innerhalb der gruppe gegeben hat
scheint es sich hierbei ohnehin eher um
eine leere box zu handeln
[Musik]
sie hatten weder angestellte noch ein
richtiges büro es war eine anomale sache
ein legaler kasten der milliarden- pumpt
und mehr nicht gepasst
wir versuchen die adresse des einzigen
luxemburgischen verwalters ausfindig zu
machen der sowohl bei castella als auch
bei care in luxemburg auftaucht
facebook
[Musik]
aber das ist alles was wir finden
konnten nur ein briefkasten
sie sind herr ackermann
jahren sie persönlich und direkt an der
unterstützung und verschleierung der
steuer position von herrn di marco
beteiligt
ich will nicht mit ihnen reden so wie
bei bizarre
[Musik]
lag er in luxemburg stützt sein
steuersystem auf die tessiner
niederlassung der lg castella dient der
diskreten entlohnung von managern die
als global listen im tessin keine
einkünfte in der schweiz beziehen können
es scheint ein gesamtpaket zu sein dass
kehring angeboten wird um so viel wie
möglich zu sparen und das mit dem tessin
verflochten ist
so wurde eigentlich das konto der
luxemburgischen gesellschaft eröffnet
und eingerichtet
die luxemburgische firma castella
benutzte ein konto der credit suisse in
lugano
das geld kam von der lg luxemburg war so
strukturiert dass es der schweiz die
stirn bieten konnte der steuer fox sitzt
im tessin lament der fiskal ähnlichen
gehen wir zurück in die tessiner sonne
im folgenden dürfen wir seine stimme
zwar nicht preisgeben aber wir können
die dialoge genauso wieder geben wie sie
stattgefunden haben ein direkter zeuge
der bisher noch nie gesprochen hat hat
sich bereit erklärt sich mit uns zu
treffen und uns zu verraten wie die
steuer architektur des unternehmens in
der schweiz aufgebaut und umgesetzt
wurde
wenn man der erste steuerzahler des
kantons ist eine bekannte marke dann
erlaubt einem sein status dinge die
andere nicht erlaubt sind wenn man einen
gast in der kaiser suite im hotel hat
verwöhnt man ihn nicht wahr nun sie
waren gäste in der kaiser suite sie
wurden verwöhnt und man hörte ihnen zu
die person die die steuerlichen
positionen der gucci manager und die
steuerstruktur des unternehmens
aufgebaut hat ist ein treuhänder mit
einem büro in lugano vom ersten tag an
im verwaltungsrat von gucci inka dem
kino
im kopf dieses zahlungssystems für die
manager war adil solar die um die
tatsache zu umgehen dass die global ist
ische pauschalregelung durch den
nachweis von auslands einkünften
erreicht wird hat la die das system in
luxemburg ausgeheckt damit die manager
die marco und bizarr die jeweils der
global ist ischen regelung nach weniger
steuern zahlen konnten er war persönlich
an der erlangung dieser pauschalsteuer
regelung für die beiden ceos beteiligt
ja wie ist das große gehirn der struktur
in der schweiz und bei alldem war gut
sie definitiv der größte kunde der firma
der treuhänder antwortete uns auch nach
mehrmaligem nachfragen nicht selbst wenn
wir persönlich in sein büro gingen wurde
uns gesagt wir sollten unsere fragen an
das französische büro von kehring
stellen
wie kam gut die ursprünglich nach
campino
die
vatikanbank lienz der city und singe
damals finanzdirektor oder gucci gruppe
hatten bei coopers & lybrand zusammen
gearbeitet und waren durch eine tiefe
freundschaft verbunden la diva
gemeindevertretern campino
monika akademie
stellt für verschiedenen unternehmen
bäckerin gruppe rund 250000 franken pro
jahr in rechnung er war aber auch
teilzeit angestellter der care in
luxembourg euro' financial investments
niederlassung mit einem festgehalt von
130.000 freundin jahr bei alg ii war es
also praktisch einen zusätzlichen
mitarbeiter auf der lohnliste zu haben
noch dazu einen schweizer um das
unternehmen glaubwürdig zu machen um den
anschein einer schweizer mehrheit in den
verwaltungsräten zu erwecken wurden
weitere in der schweiz ansässige
personen eingestellt darunter mehrere
berater
neben lg taucht der name des tessiner
treuhänders auch in den aufsichtsräten
mehrerer tessiner modeunternehmen
abercrombie tom ford und loro piana auf
die firma war auch an der gesellschaft
beteiligt dc cover besitzt eine
schuhmarke die von den italienischen
finanzbehörden wegen steuerhinterziehung
beschlagnahmt wurde mit einem eigentümer
der einen scheinwohnsitz im tessin hatte
und im lg verwaltungsrat sass seit der
ankunft von gucci im tessin auch der
berater parolo bringen er ist
mitarbeiter der anwaltskanzlei mazzoni
und schwager von marina masoni
staatsrätin und direktorin des
wirtschafts und finanzministeriums
zurzeit der ansiedlung von gucci im
tessin und heute präsident von ticino
moda die führungskräfte von gucci und
die gesamte gruppe die im laufe der
jahre ein und aus gegangen ist kamen
alle bei der firma sony vorbei um ihre
unterschrift zu leisten alle urkunden
und rechtsberatungen wurden dort
durchgeführt
[Musik]
wir haben einen interessanten austausch
von internen e-mails erhalten die unter
den topmanagern von kehring einem der
wichtigsten börsennotierten unternehmen
in frankreich verschickt wurden es wird
geschätzt dass sich die über die
tessiner niederlassungen begangene
steuerhinterziehung auf 2,5 milliarden
euro beläuft der größte fall von
steuerbetrug eines unternehmens in
frankreich jemals was die kehring
direktoren in aufruhr versetzt ist eine
frage des französischen senats der 2012
und 2013 zwei mal wegen
steuerhinterziehung ermittelt hat
bezahlt das unternehmen mitarbeiter im
ausland wo sie keine tätigkeiten ausüben
mädchens seien sie vorsichtig schrieben
sie und versuchten dann in mehreren
anläufen sich auf eine möglichst
unkonkrete formel zu einigen um den
senat damit von ihrer ehrlichkeit zu
überzeugen
tatsächlich hat gehring das für die
bezahlung der manager eingerichtete
offshore system verschwiegen und zwei
mal falsche angaben gemacht verfasser
des fragebogens ist der senator der
französischen republik eric bock leiter
der untersuchungsausschüsse zur
steuerhinterziehung
[Musik]
drei kriterien gruppe der familie pino
hat den senat zwei mal belogen ich
möchte ihnen einige dokumente und e
mails zeigen die einige kehring
führungskräfte balu und du play
geschrieben haben die sich an sie wenden
auf ihre anfrage
seien sie auf der hut zaubere version
der antwort auf den senats fragebogen
das ist unglaublich es ist ernst das
parlament kann nicht bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt verachtet werden das ist
absolut inakzeptabel der senat kann in
dieser angelegenheit nicht schweigen und
wenn es ein nachspiel gibt dann muss es
durch die justiz gehen
steuerhinterziehung ist schwerwiegend
weil sie den staatshaushalt gefährdet
das geld wird in schulen krankenhäusern
gemeinden dem was die gesellschaft
verbessern würde vorenthalten man sagt
uns dass kein geld da sei und das ist
große gruppen wie diese gibt die
frankreich jedes jahr 80 milliarden euro
verlieren ließen
80 milliarden ist das jährliche defizit
unseres landes das ist völlig
inakzeptabel ist gefährdet unsere
gesellschaft ist gefährdet die
solidarität auch die demokratie es sind
nicht die konzerne die das steuergesetz
machen es ist das parlament es ist die
politik mit einem großen p die über das
steuerrecht entscheidet diese großen
konzerne werden morgen die welt anführen
indem sie sich dafür entscheiden dort
steuern zu zahlen wo sie wollen und
natürlich dort wo es viel billiger ist
das ist definitiv inakzeptabel ein
unternehmen ist teil der gesellschaft es
ist ein element es ist dazu da
bedürfnisse zu befriedigen waren zu
produzieren dienstleistungen anzubieten
die gesellschaft voranzubringen es ist
nicht nur eine maschine die geld
produziert und geld verdient es ist auch
eine verantwortung gegenüber dem gebiet
und der gesellschaft der rhetorik wird
schon das wichtig
die menschen können diese geschichte von
steuerhinterziehung nicht mehr ertragen
auf kundgebungen hört man regelmäßig von
steuerparadiesen und steuerhinterziehung
und die menschen wollen dass wir dieses
problem wirklich an der wurzel packen
drei fussballfelder gross
330.000 kubikmeter ohne logos oder
schilder das ist die erweiterung des
gucci lagers in sant antoni no was ist
die funktion des größten gebäudes im
kanton tessin jeden tag 365 tage im jahr
kommen 50.000 waren die bereits für die
gesamte produktion von gucci und anderen
kehring marken fertiggestellt wurden mit
lastwagen in diesem lager an werden
eingelagert in kisten gepackt und
verlassen es wieder was passiert
eigentlich in dieser kurzen zeit in
tessin die rechnungen werden gedruckt
und luxus produkte made in italy werden
vom tessin aus in die ganze welt
verkauft
indem man auch auf die
verrechnungspreise spielt den verkauf
der ware die von den lieferanten zu
einem preis nach den produktionspreis
kommt und zu einem preis nahe dem der
designer leben ausgeht bedeutet das für
luxusgüter riesige menschen und
ermöglicht so die realisierung
sensationelle gewinne im tessin aber ist
die logistik eine funktion die sie
rechtfertigt ihr job ist im grunde die
logistik ja das ist richtig sind die
gehälter gut um nicht so ganz also teils
teils und sind sie hier ansässig nein in
italien sie sind italiener in italien
darf ich sie fragen wie groß die gehalts
spanne ist sie meinen je nachdem wie
viele stunden wir leisten sie werden
nach stunden bezahlt ja bei der agentur
wird nach stunden abgerechnet und der
stundensatz liegt bei so in etwa wir
bekommen etwa 17 franken pro stunde 17
franken pro stunde ja es ist alles auf
einer lüge aufgebaut wo denn im grunde
handelt es sich um ein unternehmen das
sich mit logistik befasst während man
viele jahre lang vor gab es sei ein
unternehmen das alle seine wichtigsten
funktionen hier konzentriert hat
logistik ist keine hauptfunktion
können sie erklären welche funktionen
die logistik hat warum kommt die
logistik in die schweiz
ihre präsenz in der schweiz zu
rechtfertigen wären die ansiedlung der
logistik in der schweiz war notwendig um
die rolle von lte zu etablieren und zu
rechtfertigen hering hat sich bisher
immer für den warentransport durch die
schweiz eingesetzt die logistik in der
schweiz ist ein extra schritt aus
steuerlichen gründen und so ein extra
schritt ist immer schädlich es gehen
liefert tage verloren es gibt eine
verdopplung der kosten und das sind
alles kosten die von einem steuer
kreislauf diktiert werden den wir sehr
wohl vermeiden könnten wenn die schweiz
die aus betrieblicher sicht ineffizient
ist keinen steuervorteil mehr zulässt
nun dann ist es sinnlos
nun constantini angewandter fiskale
warum beschloss die gruppe ihr eigenes
lager in sant antoni no einzurichten
falls die gruppe beschloss ihr eigenes
lagerhaus zu bauen sucht wie lange nach
einem grundstück dieser größer die
gruppe wollte sich ursprünglich nicht in
sant antoni niederlassen sondern auf
einem grundstück näher an der
italienischen grenze es machte keinen
sinn die lastwagen in der szenerie
fahren zu lassen um eine fahrt zu
unternehmen die ohnehin nutzlos und
teuer war außerdem handelte es sich um
ein problematisches grundstück das
verbessert werden musste außerdem war
der multiplikator in sant antoni no vor
der ankunft von gucci hoch wir kommen
nicht mit einem so hohen multiplikator
aber mit unserem projekt werden sie ihn
senken können weil wir ihnen eine menge
geld geben werden es gab eine diskussion
mit vital über die präventive senkung
des multiplikators und er war dem
unternehmen eine große hilfe der
multiplikator aus dem jahr 2010 vier
jahre vor der ankunft von gucci zu
beginn der verhandlungen wurde
schrittweise um 15 punkte gesenkt und
fiel auf 65 prozent im jahr 2014 dem
jahr in dem das lager gebaut wurde der
multiplikator soll nun wieder steigen da
der konzern die stadt verlässt und seine
an die stadtverwaltung gezahlten
einnahmen um mehr als die hälfte sinken
wie rechtfertigen sie diese änderung der
einnahmen
juli begründen dies damit dass die
gewinne die bisher vollständig im tessin
gesteuert wurden nun aufgrund einer
unternehmenspolitischen regelung dort
besteuert werden wo das produkt
hergestellt wird und dort wo es
weiterverarbeitet wird
er ist das prestige ein derartiges
lagerhaus in ihrem gebiet zu haben
schienen sie zunächst einmal möchte ich
sagen dass die bezeichnung lagerhaus für
diese anlage die im wert von mehreren
zehn millionen schweizer franken gebaut
wurde etwas zu kurz gegriffen ist die
lastwagen mit den waren kommen da
jedenfalls an die waren kommen an und
von dort aus werden sie sortiert
die meisten menschen die dort arbeiten
sind lagerarbeiter
im größten teil
welche vorteile bringt und brachte
dieses unternehmen dem gebiet
im allgemeinen brachte es dem gebiet vor
allem den vorteil einen großen teil des
industriegebiets und der
wirtschaftlichen ressourcen neu zu
entwickeln ressourcen die dann in form
von dienstleistungen an die bevölkerung
weitergegeben werden
und was ist mit den arbeitsplätzen
soweit wir wissen gibt es 200
arbeitsplätze von denen ein kleiner teil
von einheimischen besetzt ist
haben sie eine ahnung welche art von
gehältern im durchschnitt angeboten
werden
ich habe keine ahnung wie viel sie
angeboten haben
macht ihnen die vorstellung angst dass
das unternehmen eines tages für immer
weg gehen und dieses gebäude leer stehen
könnte
diese gruppen können wie wir wissen
gegen sich reformieren und umziehen ohne
jemanden fragen zu müssen denn es ist
ihre entscheidung das zu tun
velofahren
[Musik]
die neue anlage in dem lager in riazzino
wurde offiziell von lg angekündigt aber
ist es wirklich eine erweiterung oder
ist es nur eine bestätigung dessen dass
sie sich nur in kleineren lagern
organisieren um die logistik komplett
abzubauen
maximale diskretion das von dem
unternehmen das seit jahren der größte
steuerzahler im kanton ist scheint man
nicht einmal den namen aussprechen zu
können
wir wollten uns lediglich danach
erkundigen ob das lager hier in der
hauptsitz ist
ich weiß nichts darüber ich weiß
wirklich nichts
sie haben einen pullover auf dem
luxusgüter logistik steht ein guter
freund von mir hat ihn mir geschenkt
aber sie arbeiten hier ja aber nicht für
das unternehmen das sie gerade erwähnt
haben luxusgüter richtig ja ich arbeite
nicht für sehen wir können dazu nichts
sagen tut mir leid aber für wen arbeiten
sie
ich habe keine ahnung ich bin nicht von
hier
ich finde es seltsam dass man nicht
sagen kann für wen man arbeitet das
haben sie uns gesagt nichts zu sagen ja
das haben sie uns gesagt
das unternehmen hat sich nicht zu den
möglichen änderungen in der logistik
geäußert sicher ist dass in tessin
vorerst nur lastwagen und kisten
verbleiben ohne den vorteil von
steuereinnahmen
[Musik]